If you want something out of life,...
...if you want to change yourself,...
...if you want to acquire something,...
...if there's some goal that you want to reach,...
...changing your behaviors, overcoming negative habits,...
...it's challenging.
It's hard.
Most people go through life never discovering what their talents are.
Most people never develop their talents.
The only thing that's going to make you happy, my friend,...
...in this year or any other, is to step up.
It's to raise the standard.
It's to discover what you're capable of...
...and feel that incredible power...
...of pushing through whatever is holding you back...
...and get to the other side of more of your true self.
That's what this game is all about.
When you step into your fears and continue to push yourself to go on,...
...something happens for you.